back in October when I released my 94
things you missed an it
i theorize that Henry Bowers may have
killed his friends Victor and belch on
the way from his house to the final
showdown at Twentynine kneeble my
reasoning behind the theory was that
Henry watches the TV show seen around
Derry where Pennywise encourages him to
kill them all
then he kills his father when we next
see him at the 29 niebolt house he pulls
up in belches car with more blood on him
than before so I thought maybe there was
a deleted scene involving Henry killing
his friends and stealing the car I
declared we'd have to wait for the
blu-ray to come out to see if I was
right so fast-forward to today at time
of me making this video the blu-ray
still isn't out in my country but it has
been released in Australia and one of my
fans was nice enough to give me a heads
up the clip is only surfaced on
Instagram so far so please excuse the
quality but let's roll it
[Music]
thankfully has to a slot when you say
fellas
[Music]
[Music]
so it looks like I was spot-on with the
theory but what implications does this
have for the upcoming sequel in the book
Belgian Victor died not long after at
the hands of it in the adult portion
Pennywise exhibits the forms of both
Victor and belch to help break Henry out
of prison
Henry apologizes for leaving them to die
in the sewers all those years ago as of
right now we don't even know if Henry
survives the fall into the well in the
niebolt basement but if he does live
it's safe to say that Victor and belch
probably won't be the forms used by it
to break him out of prison that would be
one awkward car ride if Henry doesn't
live then with all four bullies out of
the picture now who's gonna be the new
scapegoat for the killings that took
place that summer let me know your ideas
in the comments also let me know if you
think this deleted scene should have
been removed or not and I know what
you're thinking cz how can I get myself
some of that stylish float merchandise
for that you're gonna want to head over
to the new C's of all the merch store
where you can find float tees sleeveless
shirts and even a mug among other
merchandise I'll leave a link in the
description but most importantly
remember to subscribe to seize these
world for new Horrors every week ring
that death bell for notifications and
I'll see you in the next one assuming we
both survive